so you're saying if you're not a woman
then you shouldn't have an opinion where
does a guy get a right to say what a
woman is
women only know what women are
are you a cat
no
can you tell me what a cat is
actually a genuine mistake I am sorry I
even came up here
I've been on like dating sites but if
you look at the people that I match with
or the people that I like my messages
there really isn't none because I
haven't found that high value meal that
I want to merrier pursue or even sleep
with I've only been nine times out of
ten they're not on dating apps
that is correct just like high value
women nine times out of ten are not on
dating apps what makes a high value
woman oh God what's that can Concepts
form to you Concepts foreign to you
modesty modesty being demure modesty
what does modesty yeah modesty and
character modestine appearance modesty
in her demeanor you just don't like it
when a woman is outspoken you're
intimidated by that [__] you just met
me like 10 minutes ago okay starting to
say you just called me a [__] you
inspected me I have not insulted you I
said that you are intimidated that you
are intimidated nobody's intimidated by
you first of all I don't know second of
all yeah it seems like you're
intimidated by somebody that like that
speaks the truth that modesty that is
okay that is your concern modesty so
yeah you just said that a high value
woman the first thing that came out of
your mouth was modesty that is at the
top things that came out at the top of
the list modesty no then why did you
name it can we can we just lower the
temperature a little bit just she's
triggered as [__] what would you say at
a feminist specifically those I think
you would consider biological women who
are in support of trans women being able
to access women's spaces like female
bathrooms and uh being able to
participate in women's sports are you
one of those feminists I am oh okay
lucky guess what is a woman uh somebody
who identifies as a woman so can I
become a woman do you have gender
dysphoria thankfully no so anyone at any
time can become a woman
uh no because anyone could have gender
dysphoria
it's it's you claim it upon yourself
you're a feminist and you you say anyone
who has gender dysphoria can transition
to become a woman at any time and you're
a feminist I am what women are you
trying to protect all women regardless
of whether or not they've transitioned I
wish you well in the coming situation
where now as a feminist you're going to
have to live under the tyranny of men
who think they're women thank you for
being here tonight
uh all right ladies name three countries
outside of U.S Canada Mexico let's throw
them into Egypt Europe Europe okay okay
um
Dubai all right good job
no helping let them answer the question
Asia
that's the only country you know is Asia
no that's not the only country but she
already named the ones that I would so
the other countries you would have said
are Europe and Dubai yeah well Europe so
your three countries are Europe Dubai
America London London okay and
can you recall the president of London
what's the capital what's the capital of
London
what is it I'm asking you is your the
country you're named I don't know wait
you're a teacher a preschool teacher got
it all right in today's society given
Evolution given the fact that as women
we can go together yeah but I'm I'm not
saying that isn't there a glitch between
what is actually happening and the
nature of what we have in our bodies I
think that's probably the conflict that
we're having right now glitching what
way in the sense that women don't feel
like they need men in the most physical
sense perhaps like naturally very
interesting women don't feel like they
need men in a physical sense because
life is soft but it's but it's but it's
[__] and it's [__] because you
still need Men by proxy one and two the
second life gets difficult you very
quickly you very quickly learn how much
you need men but women will go I'm an
independent I don't need no man because
I haven't only fans and men being my
only fans and if anyone comes up to me
I'll call a male police officer I don't
need men shut up [__] idiot of course
you do you just name your whole life
it's based on [__] men the roads are
driving along was paved by a man the
house you're living in was built by a
man the car you're driving it was
designed by a man your whole life
depends on man and the second anything
bad were to happen to you the second
physically threatened where times were
to get hard or War were to start or
famine or riots the first thing you do
is find a big strong man [__] yourself
and throw the feminism out the window
feminism goes out the [__] window the
second that the snow needs shoveling or
there's a [__] broken down car or the
tire needs changing then all that crap
vanishes it's garbage just another quick
one about Angela's question on equality
just before we've got quite a large pay
dispute happening with our Australian
women's soccer team at the moment
um is it frustrating for you as someone
who's so prominent in your sport
and we heard you say on The Ellen Show
the other day you are the richest
fighter in UFC that that sort of thing
is still going on
I think that how much you get paid
should have something to do with how
much money you bring in I'm the highest
paid fighter not because Dina and
Lorenzo wanted to do something nice for
the ladies
they do it because I bring in the
highest numbers they do it because I
make them the most money and I think
that the money that you they make should
be proportionate to the money that they
bring in
because men always just want virgins
that have hadn't had sex with anyone and
are really good girls that's it that's
and it's like you want younger women as
well so it's like that whole Predator
vibes well it's not no it is that but
that's realistically like say how it is
you want younger women that you can
manipulate here we go just to mold to
your lifestyle and it's not here we go
that's literally it okay but it's
perspective So you you're now going to
word it got a question for you you're
going to word it and say oh it's like a
woman that you know understands she's
submissive and she does all this so it's
about perspectives okay we're saying we
want a woman that we can manipulate
that's dumb right that's timid Etc okay
that doesn't understand her worth is
that fair no it's not I'm just saying
like it's perspective but but no but
that's what you're saying like that's
what men want you said someone else
that's how it sounds like you want women
what if I said women are
stupid can't make money short and weak
because they want a guy that makes more
money than them taller than them more
confident ambitious Etc that would be
ludicrous wouldn't it because I'm
demonizing what you don't tell me a
country where women is womanist policies
have landed into a first world country
and a first world situation and
sustained it listen this is not about
uh-uh you answered the question don't
tell me listen [__] see you guys need to
understand something this this woman
right here is the poster child for
what's wrong with the black community
and the problem is feminism womanism is
a way to level the sexual Marketplace
value for for unattractive women and
notice for everybody else she had no
problem saying who wants an average man
when she look like that an average
looking woman oh yeah you're average as
hell
oh yeah you're average as hell
yeah you're average as hell yeah you
look at it she triggered trigger average
ass French toe look at this average
Amber City boss City Ball it's an evil
world we live in
I do my research and the thing I'm
referring to is when Peter Hitchin said
about the rapes that occurred in Oxford
that the obviously the fact that these
were Muslims was important because if
you engage in a discourse where you
think of other people as Infidel and
think of other people as lesser that
makes you more likely to be a rapist
that's why Muslims are more likely to be
racist rapists exactly what you said
where when at 2013 look it up you wrote
it I didn't right I didn't this is the
wrong person that this is I I always
said in my research before the rain
that's just moronic to say that I didn't
check it yourself you should remember
what you write especially it's not
offensive okay you search it the reason
is that this also leads to harm right
the reason why this discourse is so
instrumental of the perpetuating
violence is obvious because apartheid
doesn't make any sense if people aren't
engaged in the discourse of racism it
would collapse under its own
Ridiculousness it has to be buttressed
by that discourse homophobic attacks
make no sense without addiction scores
that legitimizes homophobia without
playing into that discourse and being
part of that conversation transphobic
attacks make and all of the trans all of
the trans women and trans men who die in
this country in other countries makes no
sense without the discourse that Brendan
O'Neill specifically perpetuates when he
refuses to recognize their chosen gender
identity you are engaged in a discourse
of censorship you are saying that the
discourse of Islam is something that is
wrong something that should not be
allowed something that you object to
uh yeah go for it
it's absolutely not
[Applause]